une sixième soirée consécutive dans la
rue pour protester contre
l'emprisonnement d'un musicien catalan
ce dimanche des centaines de
manifestants ont défilé vers le centre
de barcelone dans le calme pour soutenir
pablo à celle ce rappeur incarcéré après
des messages sur les réseaux sociaux
dans lequel il insultait la monarchie
espagnole et la police un emprisonnement
que certains catalans estime scandaleux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je crois que nous vivons dans un état
répressif et policiers et je suis venu
réclamer des droits civils et politiques
je suis venu parce que je considère
injustes d'emprisonner un chanteur qui
ne fait qu'exprimer ses idées à travers
la musique
ce sujet relance le débat sur la liberté
d'expression dans le pays et divise la
classe politique espagnole et notamment
la coalition gouvernementale des
divergences semblent persister entre les
socialistes et le parti de gauche
radicale podemos depuis le 16 février
les rues barcelonaise sont prises
d'assaut par des rassemblements plus ou
moins violents
plusieurs affrontements ont eu lieu au
cours de la semaine entre manifestants
et forces de l'ordre
avec destruction de mobilier urbain
poubelles incendiées et magasins pillés
depuis le début des protestations
95 personnes ont été interpellées dans
toute la catalogne
d'après les autorités